This lecture I think starts with
a series of preliminaries. Uh,
but so the,
in the technical term for preliminaries
of this kind in literary study prolapses
that is to say the form of anticipation,
which in a certain sense covers
what will be talked about later.
Uh, they are, uh, prolapses
of this kind. Uh, I,
at first I wanted to say that in
entering upon the phase of this course,
which concerns a series of particular
identities as perspectives,
as points of departure for thinking
about the literary text ad of course,
for thinking about identity itself.
Um,
we come upon a,
a,
a form of,
of critical endeavor,
which is in practical
terms, incredibly rich, uh,
and productive.
Uh,
it is simply amazing how as Jonathan
Color wants to put a reading as a woman or
reading as an African
American or reading as, uh,
any of the other, uh, uh, sort of, uh,
focuses of identity that we're
going to be talking about.
It's simply amazing how
this kind of reading,
if it's done alertly transforms
everything that is to say it has a,
an incredible practical payoff.
Um, you know, last time,
uh, in the context of
the new historicism, uh,
Steven Greenleaf Greenblatt's brilliant
anecdote begins with Queen Elizabeth
Sang, I am Richard the second.
No, you not that whoa. Well,
I mean, Stephen Greenblatt isn't
concerned and investigating, uh,
a pronouncement of that
sort from the standpoint of
feminist criticism or indeed,
uh, from the standpoint of something
we'll be taking up later on gender theory,
uh, but still it's rather
than amazing thing for Queen
Elizabeth to say, isn't it?
Uh,
it suggests really that cut that it's,
that it's after all remarkable,
let she, a woman, uh,
would find herself in a
position not so much, uh,
needing to endure the kind of suffering
and peril that her own sex has
traditionally endured, but, uh,
rather and potentially enduring the
suffering and peril that one would
experience in the masculine
gender position made perhaps
even more interesting
and complicated by the fact that Elizabeth
knows perfectly well that despite the
rarity of her being Richard the second,
uh,
it's nevertheless not a unique position.
She has some subjected Mary Queen
of Scots to precisely that position.
She has deposed a and B
headitor ultimately, uh,
in just the way that she
fears the Earl of Essex.
We'll depose and behead her.
So the way in which, uh,
this remark, uh, I am Richard the
second no, you're not that, uh,
so easily commandeered and made use
of from the standpoint of the new
historicism can,
uh,
come to life in a completely different
way when we think about it, uh,
as a question of a gendered experience,
um,
is I think in itself a fascinating one.
Now I'm at the end of the last lecture,
just as by way of further
preliminary, um, I told a little fib,
I said that there were no
women in Tony the tow truck.
And of course in your prose texts,
the one that you've been clutching to
your bosom feverish Lee for the entire
semester. Uh, in your prose
text, there are no women.
There are just guys talking.
However, if to the prose text,
and I've told you about these,
you add the illustrations, uh,
and this is one of them. Roughly
speaking, I did it from memory. Um, uh,
if you add the illustrations,
you have to realize that it's not just
the cars you see the little smiles on the
faces of the cars.
It's not just the cars that are happy
about what's going on when bumpy finally
comes along and pushes Tony.
Uh,
but it's the houses in the background,
the houses in the background which
have been expressing disapproval,
uh, at the reactions of Nieto
and speedy to the predicament.
They're big frowns on the faces of
those houses in that illustration.
And now express beaming approval when
the morally correct thing is done now in
the Victorian period.
And in a certain sense,
I think Tony did the tow truck in this
regard hearkens back to the Victorian
period.
There was a poet named Coventry Pat Moore,
who actually are rather good poet
who became notorious however,
and the feminist tradition for having
written along poem in which he describes
woman as the angel in the house.
You probably,
you're probably familiar
with that expression,
but the idea is an idea which is
also I think embodied, uh, in the,
in a monumental book of some 25 years
ago by an Douglas called the feminization
of American culture.
Uh,
the idea is that moral and aesthetic and
cultural values are somehow or not or
another in the hands of women,
uh,
in the drawing room at the tea table
dictating to the agencies of society,
all of which are strictly
male prerogatives. Uh,
what a proper ethical sense
of things ought to be.
In other words,
the role of the angel in the house is
not just to wash the dishes and take care
of the kids,
although that's a big part of it.
The role of the angel in the house is
also to adjudicate the moral aspect of
life at the domestic level.
And that's exactly what these houses
obviously inhabited by angels.
How else could they be
smiling and frowning? Ah,
that's what these houses are doing.
And so it is the case after all that
there are women in Tony the tow truck.
All right. Now, as I say,
this moment is not exactly a
crossroads in our syllabus.
It's not like moving from language to
psyche to the social because obviously
we're still very much in the social,
in fact,
it's not even as though we haven't
hitherto and countered the notion of
perspective. Uh, obviously
we have in all sorts of ways,
but particularly in the work
of Bactine or Jameson, uh,
were introduced to the way in which
class conflict that is to say being of a
certain class.
Therefore having an identity gets
itself expressed in literary form.
Dialogic Lee gets itself expressed
even as the expression of either as the
expression of conflict, uh,
between or among classes, uh,
or as a more cacophonous.
And yet at the same time,
very frequently harmonious a chorus
of voices of the sort that in,
uh, notions of Carnival,
Carnival Association, uh,
and other such notions one finds
in [inaudible]. In other words,
the way in which the language of a text,
the language of a narrative or of a poem
or have a clay gets itself expressed is
already ha, eh. As, as
we've encountered it,
a question of perspective that it say
it needs to be read with notions of
identity in this case,
notions of class identity, uh,
in mind if it's to be understood.
Well,
what's interesting though,
what's also interesting though about
turning to questions of identity is that
perhaps more sharply now than hitherto,
although I have been at pains to point
out certain moments in the syllabus in
which one really does arrive
at a crossroads and you've
got to take, you can't,
you simply can't take both
paths. Uh, nevertheless, uh,
within the context of thinking about
identity in these ways as literary theory,
we begin to feel, uh, uh,
an increased competitiveness
among perspectives. I'm
going to be pointing out,
pointed this out from time to time in
the sequence of lectures that we now
undertake. But from the very
beginning, there's a, a,
a sense of competition between
actually a competition,
which is in some ways unresolved
to this day. Uh, for example,
between the feminist and
the Marxist perspective.
That is to say what is the underlying
determination of identity and
consciousness?
Is it class or gender?
Just for example, and this is
not a new topic, this is not,
this isn't a topic that we
stumble on today. Um, uh,
as a result of some belated
sophistication we have achieved,
listen to Virginia Woolf on page 600 of
a room of one's own where she says top
of the left hand column for genius.
Like Shakespeare's is not born
among laboring undereducated
survival people that
was not born in England among
the Saxons and the Britons.
It is not born today
among the working classes.
How then could it have been born among
women whose work began according to
professor Trevelyan almost before
they were out of the nursery,
who were forced to it by
their parents and held to it.
But all the power of law and custom
yet genius of a sword must have existed
among women as it must have
existed among the working classes.
Now in a way,
wolf is pulling her punches here.
She's not saying class has
priority over gender Norris.
She saying gender has priority over class.
If we're to understand the history
of the oppression of women, uh,
or the history of the limits on
the forms of women's expression,
uh,
she's pulling her punches and yet at the
same time I think we can see a point of
view and wolf's [inaudible]
room of one's own,
which is after all rather surprising.
Think of the title.
Think of the later title
of attract in some ways,
similar about sort of possible possible
scope for contemporary activity for
women. Three guineas. Uh,
these titles are grounded
in material circumstances.
Wolf stands before her audience,
her Oxbridge audience of women and says,
all she really has to say
is just this one thing.
If you're going to expect to get anything
done in the way of writing or in the
way of any other activity that's
genuinely independent of patriarchal
limitation.
You've really got to have 500 pounds
a year and a room of your own.
That's all she really says.
She has to say. In fact,
as you read through the six
chapters of a room of one's own,
you find that as if,
uh,
on an elastic band after the extraordinary
range of impressive impressionistic
thinking that each chapter manifests,
she is pulled back to this one particular
as she sees it necessary factual,
precondition material, precondition.
You want to get anything done.
You're not Jane Austin.
You're not a gene.
You're not a genius sitting on
your parlor, whisking your, your,
your novel in progress under
a piece of blotting paper.
Every time a servant comes into the
room, you know, you're not like that.
You really do need today the independence
of having 500 pounds and a room of
your own.
In other words,
I think one could show that even
in a row of one's own, which is,
which is if not the greatest,
certainly the most eloquent, uh,
so feminist treatise on the conditions
of women's writing ever written one could
show that even in that,
uh,
there is a certain priority given to the
perspective of class as opposed to the
perspective of gender. Uh, gender, uh,
will continue to be conditioned by the
effects of money and power if in fact
something isn't done.
Let's face it to redistribute
money and power on this too.
And this is a perspective which by the
way is even clearer in three guineas. Uh,
and uh, and at we're at
suggesting that, um, despite, uh,
its main agenda,
which is a feminist one,
that underlying that there is a
sense of the priority of class,
these sorts of tensions continue to
haunt not just feminist criticism,
but other forms of criticism having
to do with other forms of identity.
Really to this day, uh, conferences, uh,
featuring this variety of perspectives
very typically are develop into debates
on precisely this issue and the
one ops persons of conferences.
Of this kind are,
is the one who somehow it ones who somehow
get in the last word a and say you're
all naive. Uh, you suppose
that this is the basic issue,
but there's an underlying issue,
which is the basic issue. Uh,
and that's the one that I'm going to
demonstrate must absolutely prevail.
It's not necessarily always,
uh, the Marxist card,
which has played in this context,
although it frequently is, uh,
it could be some other card,
but it's always a card played.
It's always the last word at the
conference, which makes everybody go away.
I said, oh, I, I thought this
was about women. Oh dear.
It must be about something
else. And we will, uh, and,
and we will have to come back
to that because, uh, in a way,
the material we covered today and the
way that we're enabled to discuss it by
its own nature, uh, uh,
is something that, uh,
calls for another lecture and a
lecture that we will actually provide.
Um, there's a very real sense as I hope
to show by the end of the lecture, uh,
in which,
uh,
traditional I call this classical feminist
criticism in which traditional art,
classical feminist criticism needs to be
supplemented perhaps in the [inaudible]
sense needs to be supplemented
by something more,
which is gender theory.
Um, and I'll try to,
as I say at the end of the lecture,
I'll try to explain what that might,
what that might entail and then
come back to it when we discuss, uh,
uh, Judith Butler and Michelle
Fuoco, uh, a few lectures from now.
All right,
so run one zone is an absolutely
amazing tour de force.
Uh,
it's actually one of my favorite books.
I read it like a novel and in
many ways it is a novel. Um,
uh,
and I think immediately that might give
us pause because if Charlotte Bronte is
to be called to task for tendential
snus that is to say for writing from the
standpoint of complaint
of perceived oppression.
And if Charlotte Bronte's tendentious
dangerousness gets in the way of the full
expression of what she has to say, which
is to say the unfolding of a novel. Uh,
and if as Virginia Woolf,
I think actually rightly remarks,
at least from an aesthetic point of view,
we wonder why on earth grace
pools suddenly appears after,
after,
you know,
the sort of Jane's diatribe about wishing
that she could travel and wishing that
her horizons had been
broadened. Somehow j, uh,
Virginia will says Grace Pool, uh, is
out of place and that there's been,
there's been a rift, uh,
in the narrative fabric.
If this criticism of Charlotte Bronte is
fair and we'll be coming back to it in
other contexts, then of course it
could be turned against the narrative,
the choice of narrative style of
narrative approach in a room of one's own
itself. Uh, this I suppose,
good only strike you forcefully if you
read the whole of room of one's own all
six chapters, which I urge you to
do. Um, because it's so much fun.
If you read the whole of a room of
one's own, you'd say, well, Gee,
this is sort of a novel
to the Speaker says, Oh,
call me anybody you like not
unlike Melville speakers saying,
call me Ishmael.
You can call me Mary beaten.
You can call me Mary seat and call me
Mary Carmichael doesn't really matter. Um,
but I've had certain certain adventures,
at least that person speaking
has had certain adventures.
What's your fictitious,
um, or at least I reserve the right to
sub to have you suppose that they're
fictitious. Uh, in other words,
this is a narrative that moves quite by
design in the world of fiction and other
words, Virginia Woolf was saying
it really isn't true. As, as,
as she tells us in the first chapter that
she marry beaten after sitting at the
river thinking,
wondering what on earth she's going to
tell these young ladies about women and
fiction as she's been thinking about
that. Finally, she gets a little idea.
It's like pulling a bit of a fish out of
the river and the fish starts swimming
around in her head.
She becomes quite excited and
she walks away across the grass.
At that point up arises a beetle,
a formidable person,
you know,
wearing oxone and gowns and pointing
at the gravel path where she as an
authorized woman should be walking as the
grass is the province only for the men
enrolled in the university. Uh, and so,
and then she has repeated
encounters of that kind.
She goes to the library on thinking Lee
only to be told by an elderly race like
gentlemen, that since she's a woman, she
needs a letter of introduction to get in.
Um, and, and so it's her
day, her fictitious day,
thinking about what on earth she say
to these young women about women and
fiction, uh, begins
somewhat unpleasantly, um,
as a presented fiction and other words,
a room of one's own is in a sense,
a novel. It continues, um, uh,
with a very pleasant lunch that she has.
She's been invited to the campus
as a distinguished writer.
It's okay to be a novelist, um, uh,
to be a woman who's a novelist
as long as you, uh, as, as, as,
as long as you don't rock
the boat too much. Um,
and in that respect,
in that regard,
she can have been invited to such a
lunch has is very pleasant lunch because
it's provided by men, uh, in an
atmosphere which is designed for men.
Then she goes to visit a friend who is
teaching at this fictitious college.
Uh, she has dinner with a friend in
that college, has dining hall, uh,
and the dinner is extremely unfair,
earlier inferior and plain. Uh,
and then they go to her rooms,
uh,
and they start talking about
the conditions in which
this college was built.
Bunch of women in the 19th century had
all they could do to raise 30,000 pounds,
no frills. Thank you very much.
None of them had any money.
There were no major donor donations. And
so the grass never gets cut. The brick,
the brick is playing an unadorned.
Um,
and that's the way life is in this
particular women's College. Uh,
then, uh, she, uh, the
next day she goes to,
she goes to the library because she
decides she's really got to find out
something about what people
think of women. Um, and so,
you know what, you know,
what is a woman? I don't
know exactly. So I'd better,
I'd better look it up in the library.
And she finds out that hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of men have written
books about women, uh, you
know, the inferiority of women.
They moral sensitivity of women,
the lack of physical strength
of women on and on and on.
And she lists them as items in the
library catalog actually are there in the
library catalog. All
of them, of course, uh,
getting themselves expressed in these
hundreds and hundreds of books about women
by men. Well, this is very
frustrating, but as you can
imagine, it's a cause. It's a,
it's an occasion for wonderful satire.
Uh,
what has to say 10 inches a satire,
because obviously it's male bashing.
And my point is,
my point is that she wouldn't
let Charlotte Bronte get
away with that. You know,
Charlotte Bronte has,
sorry,
Charlotte Bronte has to suspend her anger.
Virginia Wolf wants to say if she's going
to get the whole of what's on her mind
expressed. Well, Virginia Wolfe
who is of course not sort of,
doesn't sound very angry. Um, but you
could well be mistaken about that.
Uh, she's venting her
anger in comic effects. Uh,
Virginia Woolf allows herself
because that really is the case. Uh,
a measure of anger. Uh, so, so it is in
that chapter, then she goes home, uh,
and the rest of the rest of the room
of one's own takes place in one's home.
She's in her study pulling books
off the shelf of her library.
Uh, and this is more or less
chronological. It starts with the,
with a time when she looks, uh, where, uh,
on the shelf where the
women writers ought to be.
And there aren't any women
writers. Uh, and then later, yes,
there are women writers. Uh, there are
quite a few novelists. Uh, and then later,
uh, in the trying to, in century women,
writers get a little bit more
scope for their activity. Um,
and as she passes all of this and review,
uh,
we continue to get her reflections on
the state of literary possibility for
women in literary history.
So that is,
that's the structure of a room
of one's own, uh, overall. And,
uh,
it is within this structure,
which is an impressionistic and narrative.
Undoubtedly novelistic structure. I
mean, there, there are precedents for it.
Oscar Wilde's portrait of Mr wh is,
is one in particular,
but which is w, but which is, um, in a,
in a way what it's talking about.
It is a novella.
Uh, and in the context
of the Novella, as I say,
there's a certain tension
or contradiction, uh,
in an author who is allowing
herself tendentious opinions,
uh, while denying the right
to have such opinions, uh,
on the part of one of her predecessors.
As you can imagine,
what she says about Charlotte Bronte
has been, has been controversial,
uh,
in subsequent feminist criticism.
There are a number of ways in which
feminist critics feel that, uh,
Virginia Woolf is misguided
or needs to be supplemented.
Uh, and this is one of them by
and large feminist good ex, uh,
feel that Charlotte Bronte or other
writer has the right to be 10 dentures.
Uh, we'll have more to say about, uh,
Virginia Woolf's criterion
of Androgyny, uh, uh,
which is not thinking
like either sex in park.
We'll come back to
that. Um, but, but, but,
but most feminist criticism has felt,
uh,
for a variety of reasons that, um, uh,
androgyny isn't necessarily
the ideal, uh, uh,
toward which women's pros
a ought to be aspiring, uh,
and Take Virginia Woolf to task
therefore for having taken this view of
Charlotte Bronte. Now, yes,
feminist criticism has taken a room of
one's own to task and a variety of ways,
but at the same time,
and I think this is freely enhancing,
we acknowledged a by a feminist criticism.
It is amazing when you read the whole
text and even when you read the excerpts
that you have in your anthology,
it is amazing how completely Virginia
Woolf's arguments anticipate,
uh, the subsequent course of the
history of feminist criticism.
I just want to point out a few
of the ways in which it does, um,
as show older points out.
The first phase of modern
feminist criticism, uh,
was the kind of the kind of work that
primarily pays attention to men's
treatment of women in fiction.
Uh, uh, Mary elements,
uh, Mary almonds book of, of, uh,
of of 1968 called thinking about women,
Kate Millet's,
a sexual politics,
uh,
in 1970 are both books which,
um,
which are focused primarily on
sexist male novelists, uh, who,
uh, whose demeaning treatment
of women, uh, as something that,
that the feminist perspective
perspective needed to bring out.
This criticism is superseded in,
uh,
Elaine Showalter's account by what she
calls and prefers a gyno criticism or the
gyno critics.
Uh,
and Gyno criticism is not so much
concerned with men's treatment of women in
fiction as with the place of women
as writers in literary history and as
characters,
uh,
regardless whether their characters in
men's or women's books in their own right
in, uh, the history of
fiction. In other words.
In other words, Gyno criticism turns, uh,
turns the topic of feminist
criticism around 19,
late sixties, and seventies,
and early seventies,
from the history of oppression by men
to the history of the a or the women's
tradition. Now, this, this sense of the,
of the unfolding of things,
it seems to me is already fully present.
And Wolf,
she too wants to talk about
the possibilities for women
writers about the need,
uh, for women writers to feel that
they're not alone and above all.
At the same time. However, uh,
she frames this emphasis
on the woman's perspective.
She frames it with the
sort of, uh, of, of,
of trenchant, uh,
frequently satirical, uh,
observations about men's
treatment of women, uh,
man's way of demeaning women and
keeping them in their place. Um,
as for example, uh, all the men,
most of them professors who
wrote books about women, uh,
as she discovered, uh,
in the British library.
All of this is very much in the
tradition of that first phase of feminist
criticism that show Walter
identifies, uh, with, uh, Elman,
uh,
and millet and others of that generation.
So the capacious snus of
Wolf's approach, um, is, uh,
in one sentence can be understood as
precisely her ability to bridge, uh,
both sorts of modern tradition,
uh,
no longer chronic chronological,
as show altered presents
them as being correctly,
but rather as a kind of simultaneity,
simultaneity, uh, in which,
um, in, in, in which
the emphasis on, on, on,
on men's marginalization of women and
the emphasis on women's consciousness and
traditions, uh, can be, uh, uh,
set forth at the same time.
Now,
also in Virginia Woolf, there's
ha there's, there's what, um, uh,
since the publication of the fascinating
book by Sandra Gilbert and Susan goober
called the madwoman in the
attic. This is also, uh,
an allusion to Jane Eyre.
You remember Bertha,
the madwoman in the attic of Jane Eyre,
um,
since the publication of a, of
the madwoman in the attic. Um,
feminist criticism has,
has talked about the mad woman thesis,
the idea, in other words, uh,
that because they could not, um,
um,
openly express themselves creatively as
writers or as artists of other kinds,
uh,
women were forced to channel
their creativity into
subversive divis and perhaps
psychologically self destructive, as in,
for example, Charlotte Perkins Gilman,
uh, the, uh, the yellow
wallpaper, uh, perhaps, um,
self destructive forms. And, uh,
you find wolf already on page,
on page 600, uh, Eh,
just actually below the passage about
class and gender that I read before you
find her touching on this
madwoman theme long before, uh,
Gilbert and Gavar, she
says, when, however,
one reads of a witch being duct or of
a woman possessed by devils of a wise
woman selling herbs,
and then of course she ads and even have
a very remarkable man who had a mother
there.
In other words,
a one strongly suspect that there's
a person who's creativity has been
oppressed, uh, and, uh,
unfortunately channeled,
uh, in, uh, unsocial or
anti social directions. Um,
and this, uh, as I say is, uh, is, is,
is a tradition that sustained,
uh,
it still exists in show alter
when she says on page 13,
83, I mean, it's not just Gilbert
and goober. Uh, in other words,
when show Walter says on page 1383,
um,
she does,
I can't say that I think she does.
Uh,
uh, yes, yes, yes, yes. I, I,
what I wanted to say about
show Walter, um, is that, uh,
in her gyno critical perspective,
that is to say her,
her insistence on, are
registering chronicling, uh,
becoming familiar as scholars with,
uh,
the history of women as well as
the history of women's writing. Uh,
the recognition of such forms
of repression as witchcraft,
as madness,
as urbalism as whatever it might be,
a need to be, need to be
taken into account. Um,
also very much on the mind of
wolf already as it still is,
particularly for Showalter,
because this is show up to
his understanding of the
task of Gyno criticism is
the notion that one needs a tradition.
That one of the great difficulties and
shortcomings facing the woman's writer is
that a yes,
there are a few greats,
the same ones always named Austin.
The Bronto has George Elliot.
There are a few grades,
but there is not a sense of an ongoing
tradition of a developing tradition
within which one could write.
So that a wolf on paid six
oh six right hand column
talks about, um, the
man's sentence. You know,
the difficulty of coming to
terms with, uh, with, uh,
not having,
not just a room of one's own,
but a language of one's own,
uh,
toward the top of the right hand column.
Perhaps the first thing she would find
setting pen to paper was that there was
no common sentence ready for her.
Use all of the literary models,
all the models of novelistic pros,
uh, most of them in any case, uh,
are developed, are, are, are,
are, are engendered male, um,
because, uh, the
atmosphere of writing, uh,
and this is a point that we'll be getting
too soon. The very fact of writing, uh,
is something that we have to understand
as having a male stamp on it.
Uh, further down the right hand
column, that is a man sentence.
She's just quoted a long sentence
that is a man sentence behind it.
One can see Johnson Gibbon and the rest,
it was a sentence that was
unsuited for a woman's use.
Charlotte Bronte with all her splendid
gift for Bros stumbled and fell with that
clumsy weapon in her hands.
George Eliot committed atrocities with it.
That beggar description,
Jane Austin looked at it and laughed
at it and devised a perfectly natural
shapely sentence, proper for her own
use and never departed from it. Thus,
with less genius for writing
than Charlotte Bronte.
She got infinitely more said Jane Austin.
And by the way,
this is disputable because,
um,
certainly it's possible to understand
Jane Austen's pro style as emerging from
the work of Samuel Johnson and
Samuel Richardson in particular. Uh,
so it is disputable,
but at the same time,
wolf point is that that w that Austin
was able to shake herself free from this
terrible problem of wanting
to say something, but finding,
uh,
that one doesn't have one's own language,
a language suitable to a
appropriated by and for.
And as one's identity for saying it.
So I want to write as a woman,
as a woman, I want to say the
things that a woman wants to say,
but all I've got to say it, which is
a man sentence, that's a wolf's point.
Um, and of course it has,
uh, it has, uh, many, uh,
and long ramifications.
It is, uh, I'm, I'm,
I'm holding at bay,
um,
the criticism of a great deal of this
that has to be leveled at it by feminist
criticism and genders,
gender theory roughly since 1980.
But in the meantime,
uh,
the ramifications are interesting and
they are reinforced by the theoretically
very sophisticated wing of feminist
criticism that we call French feminism.
Some of you may know the work of,
uh, of, of loose [inaudible]. He got,
Hey, a lens, see sue,
a writers of this kind of insist that
there is such a thing as women's language
women, right? Not just, you know,
with their heads in their phalluses,
but with their whole bodies.
Uh,
women don't write a carefully
constructed periodic sentences, women,
right?
Ongoing paratactic impressionistic,
a digressive, uh, ad hoc sentences, uh,
that this is a sentences without ego,
uh,
being without structure, more or less
corresponding to being without ego.
We'll come back to this in a minute
and show Walter, but in the meantime,
fresh feminism was willing to settle on.
And four and I,
Dhea of women's writing and implicitly
behind this idea and idea of what a woman
is,
that it's very easy to,
to identify as somehow or
another, um, essentially rising.
Why can't a woman, right, a rigorous
periodic sentence after all,
that's the kind of sentence that Jane
Austin did in fact. Right? Uh, why can't,
why can't, um, uh, integrate in a, in,
in a whole variety of ways that one that
one might think of, why can't a woman,
uh, if she is to be free to
be whatever she wants to be,
write a sentence, which isn't
necessarily of this, uh,
gendered feminine sort.
Um,
why does women's writing,
in other words have to be women's writing?
It seems to me that this,
that, that it is free.
It is French feminism and the critique,
the possible critique of French feminism
that Virginia Woolf is anticipating in
advance when she embarks on this perilous
idea of Androgyny of the kind of mind
that needs to be both male and female.
Uh,
and that needs to write in a way that
Virginia Woolf says is actually very sexy,
uh, precisely in the moment when
one is not thinking about one's sex.
Uh, the moment, in other words,
when there is no longer a question of
the man sentence and the woman's hands,
I think it has to be said that although
one could emphasize in a room of one's
own this sort of advanced criticism of
French feminism and also have the idea
that there is essentially something that
we call woman and I'm not through with
that topic.
I think it has to be said that although
we could read a room of one's own in
this way,
at the same time,
we have to recognize an ambivalence on
Virginia Woolf's part on this subject.
There is a difference between
her insistence that Jane
Austin wrote like a woman
that is,
that she shrugged off the tyranny of
the man sentence and wrote her own
sentence, uh, her own kind of sentence,
a woman sentence regardless whether
or not that is actually in literary
historical terms. True. Uh,
the idea on the one hand that it's
important to write like a woman. Uh,
and the idea on the other hand that
it's important to write androgynously we
have to,
we have to concede I think
to the impressionistic
form of these lectures that
she's giving.
Uh,
we have to concede that she waivers
on this point that there is that,
that somehow or another,
well,
it's very difficult to pin in wolf the
question whether there is essentially
something to be called women's writing.
Just as the question behind that,
whether there's essentially something to
be called woman or the question on the
contrary,
whether the ideal of all writing is to
shed as full as it can precisely it's
gendered aspects. Uh, there
is, there is perhaps a kind of,
uh,
creative or rich inconsistency on
this point that it should be said.
One also fines and needs to take
into account in reading a womb,
a room of one's own.
All right.
Now getting a little
closer to the, uh, to, uh,
to this whole question of beyond,
uh, the Gyno critical because, uh,
show Walter for example, and talking
about the history of the novel, uh,
talks about those three
phases. First, the fee,
the feminine,
that the phase in which women try very
much to write as though they were a man
by deferring completely to male values,
uh,
in all the ways that they
can, uh, perhaps, um,
introducing a kind of, uh, uh, again, um,
Angel in the house, uh, cultural, um, uh,
a benevolence and benignity into
perspectives of men that can be sometimes
rather militaristic and harsh. Uh,
but nevertheless hiding behind,
uh, frequently male names, curve bell
act and bell, George Elliot and so on.
Um, and, uh, not really,
uh, not really, uh,
entering into questions of, um, uh,
of the place of women and
society. A show, Walter then says,
this is a phase supplanted by a feminist
moment in the history of the novel in
which novels as the late work
of Mrs Gaskell, for example,
and other such novels become 10 dentures.
Uh,
and the place and role of women becomes
the dominant theme of novels of this
kind. Uh, it's a plant. And by the way,
this takes a wolf's critique
critique of Charlotte Bronte,
a little bit out of chronology because
presumably Charlotte Bronte belongs to
what show Walter is calling the female
phase and the history of the novel. Um,
but, uh, and,
and so it's interesting that wolf finds
a kind of Tropo feminism damaging to the
texture of Jane Eyre already
in Charlotte Bronte's novel.
And then finally, uh, what, what
Elaine Showalter likes best,
the supplanting of the feminist novel
because a Elaine show Walter to is nervous
about the 10 benches of fiction,
uh,
does the planning of that by what
she calls the female novel. Um,
which is the novel that simply takes for
granted the authenticity and legitimacy
of woman's part of you writes from
that part of you. But as in Virginia,
Woolf having shed or shaken
off the elements of, uh,
anger or adversary consciousness
that, uh, earlier, uh,
novels had typically manifested.
Uh,
and this is very much very
similar in the history.
This history of the novel is very similar
to what show Walter is doing with her
sense of the history of recent feminist
criticism that's in two phases.
First, the feminist as she calls it, uh,
when the treatment of men of women
by men in fiction is the main focus.
And then the Gyno critical,
which is the appropriation for
women of a literary tradition,
show Walters at pains to
point out that the most,
much of the most important work
of recent feminist scholarship,
the feminist scholarship of the 1970s
is end simply the unearthing of an
expanding of a cannon of women's writing.
Uh,
not exclusively novelistic
because there had been a time, uh,
when,
um,
the novel was sort of half conceited
to women as a possible outlet for their
writing. But this concession
was accompanied by the, um,
by the sovereign assertion that they
couldn't write poetry and plays. Uh,
and so an expansion of the cannon such
that all forms of writing are available
and made visible and recognized as
actually existing in a tradition,
uh,
so that we can trace women's writing
as show Walter puts it from decade to
decade and not from great
book, two great book. Uh,
so that there really is a tradition
comparable to the male tradition that one
can think about,
think within a and draw on
as a creative writer oneself.
Uh,
so both show alters history of the novel
and her history of modern feminist or
modern women's criticism.
One had better say, uh,
and at the point when it is still a
question of the woman's perspective,
but this raises a question and I mean,
and, and it's, and it's, it's, uh, I've,
I've been touching on it in a
variety in a variety of ways,
but it really raises the question
that has to hunt,
thinking of this kind,
and we're going to be encountering
it again and again and again. Uh,
as we move through other forms of identity
perspective in criticism and theory,
the raises the question whether if I say
that a woman or women's writing is of a
certain sort,
that is,
that is if I identify a woman in a way
that I take somehow to be recognizable,
let's say identify a woman as intuitive,
imaginative, impressionistic, sensitive,
illogical,
opposed to reason,
our refuser of that periodic sort of
subject predicate sentence that we
associate with men's writing.
I can appropriate that for women like
the French feminists and I can identify
women in so doing as such people.
But isn't that simply inverting what men
in Virginia Woolf's discover isn't in
the British Museum in the second
chapter of a room of one's own?
Isn't that just inverting all the
negative values that men have attached to
women all along?
Isn't it ultimately to accept
men's opinions of women
men's ways of saying that
because they are avatars of
reasons, science, logic, uh,
and all the rest of it,
isn't it?
Isn't it a way of saying that the head
is higher than the heart and accepting,
in other words,
the lower or inferior status
of this Oregon to this Oregon,
even though one supposes oneself to
have trans valued them and insisted in
promoting women's consciousness that
the heart is higher than the head.
What hasn't done anything?
In other words to the essential
identities that have governed patriarchal
thought from the beginning.
It is precisely this characterization
of women that has enabled and,
and gendered patriarchy. And so,
and this is where the problem,
this is where the theoretical
problem arises and it calls forth,
it calls for it seems to me, uh, uh,
a sense that somehow or another one
has to put the possibility and there's
really no other way to say it.
And this is something that Judith
Butler frequently says and, and,
and people who work in
the mode of Judith Butler,
one has to put the suggestion,
but perhaps the best thing one can say
as a feminist is there's no such thing as
a woman. There is no
woman. Now, of course,
this is perilous and this is what,
and this is,
and this is what drives such at such
an unfortunate wedge in the midst of
feminist thought in real life,
in real material existence.
There are certainly are women, they
are oppressed by laws. They are,
they are oppressed by men,
uh, and their, and, and their,
their rights and their very lives need
to be protected with perpetual vigilance.
The idea,
in other words,
the theoretical idea that there's no
such thing as a woman is not an idea that
can be sustained in life.
And yet at the same time,
the implications of what the language
of identity politics is always calling
essential ism.
The implications of saying
woman is one particular thing,
and it might be better if we said
woman was one particular thing,
but it was something other than what men
have been saying she was all along. But,
but making the problem worth saying that
woman is one particular thing, which is,
uh, just what men have always said, she
was only, it's a good thing, right? That,
that, that, that positions of this
kind taken up in this way. Uh,
despite the fact that there are absolutely
necessary for practical feminism,
for real world feminism are nevertheless,
uh,
detrimental to a more sensitive
theoretical understanding of gender.
Um, and of the possibilities of
gender. It's all very well to be,
um, to be, you know, intuitive
and emotional and, and,
and impressionistic.
Uh,
but one last to say two things about
that and the first place a guy gets to be
that if he wants to write,
and in the second place,
why does a woman have to be that?
Right? And it's perfectly clear,
it's perfectly clear in both cases that
there are exceptions which go vastly
beyond the exception that proves the rule.
It's perfectly clear that in both cases,
uh,
there are sensibilities across
gender that completely mix up,
uh, and, and, and discredit
these categories. Uh,
and so for all of those reasons, uh,
there's a problem. Uh, just very quickly,
just I wanted to point
out that, that, I mean,
looking at show Walters
essay that this is a bind,
that criticism around 1980
really hasn't gotten past.
I'm not going to take,
it's time's up.
I'm not going to take time to quote
passages, but notice, uh, her animus.
And here in a way we go
back to the beginning,
her animus against Marxism and
structuralism on the grounds.
And of course we've said this ourselves
on the grounds that both of them present
themselves as sciences. Aha. There
are gendered male, you know, uh,
Marxism and structuralism aren't anything
we want to have to do with because
this is just, uh, Virginia
Woolf's beetle, uh,
raising its ugly head again and
imposing its will through it.
Superior rationality, uh, on women. Uh,
so we don't want any of that. What we
want instead is a form of criticism.
And this is what she says at the end of
the essay on pages 1385 and 1386 what we
want instead is a form of criticism
that evades scientific city,
a form of criticism that engages with
the reality of texts and of the textual
tradition,
but doesn't trouble.
It's pretty little head doesn't trouble
it's head with theoretical matters.
In other words,
this socio writes itself from the logical,
from the old,
from overarching structure,
from scientific city show altar leaves
herself in this position and a sir and,
and, and she leaves feminist
criticism in this position as, um,
how might one put it,
um,
a colonized enterprise that can do
anything at likes as long as it's not
reasonable. Uh, and if that's
an and, and if that's the case,
then of course it imposes an essential
Ising limit on the possibilities of
feminist criticism just as of course,
the characterization of men's criticism,
uh,
in the way that it's characterized.
Needless to say also
imposes limits on that, uh,
fair and legitimate limits or
perhaps exaggerated limits, uh,
is open to question that's not
nearly as important to point as the,
the reminder, uh, that, um,
there's a kind of marginalization of the
possibilities for a feminist criticism,
uh,
involved in saying that it
has to be something other
than the sort of thing that
Marxist instructure was paradigms
make available. Uh, okay.
Now I think that,
uh,
Henry Louis Gates will have a very
influenced by buck teen will have a very
interesting way of coming to terms with
this question of what's available for a
marginalized minority criticism,
uh,
once it avoids or has succeeded in
avoiding the terms of the mainstream
criticism. Uh, and I want you
to read gates his essay, uh,
with that particularly in mind,
then we'll come back with the question of,
as it were,
the future of feminist criticism,
feminist criticism in a way since 1980,
uh,
when we turn to the work of
the gender theorists, uh, in
particular, Judith Butler.